hello everyone.welcome cool to see that
that many people found their way to the
dungeon that is room five I had not been
up here before I ended up on floor three
and then two and then four and then had
to walk to basically Scotland to get
here
um anyhow so I'm going to talk about
parents and now or software powers in
general but I'll be using c-sharp and
net to show show some samples if you're
not here to listen about patterns you're
probably in the wrong room
it's early I know but hopefully you're
all here to listen to this so my name is
Chris Klug I work as a software
developer / architect / public speaker
so I have a weird employment situation
where a substantial part of my life is
spent going to conferences and talking
about different things
I feel interesting to talk about my boss
thinks that's a really crap idea but his
boss thinks that is a really good idea
for my company to go around and share
knowledge so he prompts my boss yeah and
I've done some florals and stuff and
things like that but nothing on patterns
patterns is kind of a new thing for me
to go around to talk about it's actually
my first time ever doing this
presentation so hopefully it I don't go
too much over I assume if I just use up
about 15 minutes of your break after
this session that's fine right okay okay
good um so what are software patterns I
thought before we started we're gonna
have a little look at what software
patterns are and basically I went to
Wikipedia to figure out what that was
you know you send in an abstract for a
conference and then when you get the
talk you go to Wikipedia and you figure
out what you can talk about that's how I
do my talks and it says that it's a
software software design pattern is a
general reusable solution to a commonly
occurring problem within a given context
in software design makes sense right
interesting part here out of all of that
that was also part of a whole page but I
took that out because I thought that was
the best part of it
it's like okay so it's a general
reusable solution which is what
everybody gets stuck on that's software
powders awesome because we can reuse
them and their general and we can do
everything with them but they generally
missed a little part that says within a
given context we don't go ahead and find
a software pattern we like and then try
and find a problem we can solve with it
okay it's the other way around we have
software patterns because you are
probably running into problems while
doing your job that other developers
have run into previously likely you're
running into problems every day that
developers have been running into since
the beginning of coding in general so
we're looking at really old things if
you start looking up at looking at
software patterns if you google that
it's interesting because you're always
just going to find I think it's 24
patterns it's the gold standard there
are 24 patterns no one else really
counts and that's because there was a
book released like the Gang of Four that
covered 24 design patterns I'm going to
show you some of those but I'm also
going to look at some other ones but the
interesting thing about those design
patterns which are pretty much the the
well-known ones that most people have
heard of at some point the book was
released in I think 1994 so we're
talking about really old things here but
they're still kind of valid to what
we're doing today we can make some
changes to them we can update them we
can bring them in to the 21st century
because we've got new features in our
code we can do things in c-sharp that
wasn't possible to do with code in 94 so
we can we can update them and I have
done that to some of the demos I've
written my own version of them and not a
proper copy of what they decided on so
it is not a solution to everything keep
that in mind it's a specific thing and
not something where you go this thing
I've now learned the visitor pattern
that is going to solve every problem
I've ever had
doesn't work like that so
I'm gonna look at some cutting some
parents and when I got this talked about
rather when I came up with this talk I
decided that I'm gonna be cover a bunch
of different patterns in an hour I'm
just gonna go through like a hundred
different patterns to show why they're
really cool and then I realized I've got
an hour and if you want to spend a
little bit of time on every pattern you
can't really do a hundred powers in an
hour it would be really really brief and
really boring so I had to scale it down
and I I've scaled it down to the bare
minimum there is source code available
after the the session on on github I
just uploaded it about seven minutes ago
so you can go and find it it will
contain other things than what I'm
talking about it contains all the code
you'll see but it will also contain some
other patterns because I decided I'm
going to do all of these really cool
patterns and then they kind of got
killed off while doing the presentation
so you'll get a bit more source code but
I did decide that I want to go and look
at some patterns that are kind of
confusing I want to look at some really
cool patterns there is in particular one
pattern that is very very well used all
over the world and is very misunderstood
that I want to cover and there are a
couple of little useful ones as well
it's like little nuggets that aren't
really that impressive they're pretty
simple but they do make your life a
little bit easier which is kind of what
you want to do with patterns so I've got
them grouped into this and I said I've
kept them as small as I can or the
number is as low as I can yeah as I
mentioned before if you go and look at
the original design patterns they're
often really old most of the parents are
old how many of you were even building
software professionally in 1994 is one
hand so just imagine that these patterns
on top of that they weren't conceived in
1994 they were conceived earlier than
that so I was barely a teenager by the
time that they wrote those patterns but
they're still interesting but as I said
code has changed c-sharp is much more
modern has a bunch of features that they
don't have so
it's often based around bass classes and
inheritance and I've decided not to use
a bunch of bass classes and inheritance
because I personally don't like
inheritance I I prefer composition over
inheritance so basically my samples are
a little bit different the first time is
I want to call cover or a group of
patterns and that's why I put them into
the confusing group can anybody explain
to me the difference between these five
patterns
not a single person might be while
you're in the room listening to me talk
about patterns but okay how many of you
have heard of all these five patterns
okay so most of you have heard about all
the five patterns but most non of you
would say that you can explain what they
are and actually you are probably using
every single one of these or have done
at some point but they are sort of
lumped together and they're really hard
to get a grasp on which one is decorator
and what is an adapter and what's the
difference between an adapter and the
facade and things like that so I thought
I'll start out here and I'll start out
with the adapter pattern so we can see
what that is now basically go through
each one of them and you can see the
differences once again I went to
Wikipedia the the source of all
knowledge in the world wikipedia says
the adapter pattern is a software design
pattern that allows the interface of an
existing class to be used as another
interface okay so what is the problem
we're trying to solve well say that you
have a class that all I'd rather you
have an interface I've turn it around
but I would say you have an
implementation that you want to use but
the interface for that implementation is
wrong so you want to write a logger so
you're writing an asp.net core
application you need your logger to
implement the AI logger interface for
that to work right but you want to use
some logger that you've written before
you want a log use log for net or
whatever so what you create is an
adapter you create a class that
internally has an instance of the
implementation that you won't use but
externally has an API
an interface that looks like the
interface that you want to use so all is
doing is basically adapting calls so
when the eye logger dot worn is called
or whatever the interfaces you might
just have a simple one-liner that goes
log4net dot log and then passing in worn
as a enum instead because that's the
interface that they are using instead so
it's basically just a wrapper class that
doesn't make any changes at all it
doesn't change the functionality it
doesn't do anything all it does is
mapping an interface that you need to an
implementation that has the wrong API or
the wrong interface so if you look at
this basically you have an intern a
client app that needs an ilogger cause
log on the ilogger interface actual
implementation is the log4net
adapter the log4net internally has an
instance of some form of log4net logger
thingy and adapts the log method method
from the eye logger interface to an info
call on the log Fernet instance instead
so it's just adapting calls very very
thin very simple class I assume that
most do you have written this at some
point okay which then takes us to the
decorator the decorator is interesting
because it's very very similar and
that's where people's that's why I've
grouped them together because they kind
of do the same thing they're all code
wise kind of similar so the decorator
says the decorator pattern allows allows
behavior to be added to an individual
object dynamically so the description of
what the pattern does is very very
different but the actual implementation
looks very similar which is why people
get tripped up when you sit down you're
coding it you go oh this is an adapter
no it's actually decorator so the
problem that we're trying to solve with
the decorator is that you have an
implementation of something that does
most of what you need and you want to
use that you don't want to rewrite that
because you need to add some new
functionality so you need what you've
got and then some more you need to
decorate your existing class with more
functionality
an example would be I've used it for
caching for example so you have a
caching decorator the caching decorator
has the same interface as my whatever
repository or whatever I'm using but
internally it has an instance of the
thing that I want to use so say that I
want to do let's ignore caching let's do
it batching I want to batch my log
writes so I want to be able to just pump
things into my log log system but I want
to batch my log logging so basically it
just writes every ten messages forever
so it doesn't become to chat into the
database I already have my log
implementation that logs to the database
what I do is I create a log adapter or a
decorator which is like the batching log
decorator it has the batching logic it
looks like an ilogger and all it does it
has the batching logic but whenever it
needs to write the stuff their database
it has an instance of a logger
internally so basically it wraps an
instance of a logger but add some
functionality on top of it so it's the
same API but adds functionality to it
and then you can wrap many of them so
you can have a decorator that reference
is an ilogger
which actually is another decorator that
references another eye logger which
could be another decorator that
references another eye logger and you
can create these chains of objects
without inheritance which means that I
can have an ilogger and then I can add
oh it would be cool to have batching in
this project so I'm gonna add batching
to it oh by the way it would be kind of
cool if I could add environment
information to the log system
automatically so I didn't have to pass
in local environment information all the
time I'll have an environment or
decorator that does that for me and we
can use kind of build these layers on
top of what we've got with new
functionality so if we look at that the
logger implementation here once again
client app has an ilogger
cause log on the ilogger but what it's
actually got as the implementation is a
batch decorator the batch decorator
wraps an instance of log4net logger but
it doesn't wrap it doesn't say inside of
the batch decorator new log4net logger
because in that case we're talking about
an adapter the decorate
has an internal instance of ilogger so
it's agnostic towards what it's actually
wrapping its wrapping an abstract thing
which means that this thing will write
out the log thing to look for net but
the batch decorator will make sure that
it only makes those calls every X amount
of time wherever the X amount of log
increase or something like that and then
you can go ahead and you can basically
decorate your batch decorator with an M
info decorator in this case that adds
environment information same sample as I
had before client app is none the wiser
it just goes I have an ilogger that
works the environment info decorator has
no idea what's actually happening
underneath I've just got an eye info or
NSRI logger and we can build as I said
these chains of functionality to it very
common scenarios as I said would be for
example caching you have a repository
where you can go and get data and that
has no caching built in because that's
not its concern and then you add a
decorator on top of your repository that
has caching built in so that you get a
cache layer on top of it which is kind
of neat because it means that you can
add and remove the caches you feel like
so it's a wrapping thing just like the
adapter but instead of just adapting
from one API one interface to another it
has the same interface as the thing it
wraps but it adds functionality on top
of it make sense anyone ever try it very
few it's actually quite a neat power
it's very simple but it does offer a lot
of flexibility and facade another one of
these kind of does the same thing but no
role definition of a facade is an object
that serves as a front-facing interface
masking more complex underlying or
structural code okay this is actually
quite a neat thing once again they're
the patterns I've chosen are things I
like because they make my life easier so
the problem we're facing in this case is
that you're interfacing with a system
that is really complex it needs you to
know a whole bunch of how that system
works and it's really complex and to
perfectly honest I've been on a ton of
projects where
we're interfacing towards a third party
system which is really complicated and
there's like one developer on the team
that has all the knowledge of how to
talk to that system and we can't really
get that throughout the team so what you
do is you put in a facade you let that
developer who knows how that system
works put in what is called a facade so
the facade solves this by simplifying
the API say that you have a car car has
all of these things to be able to start
the car you actually need to insert the
key and you have to press the clutch and
you have to turn the key right we'll do
that simply but it was a simplest
example I could come up with instead of
having to figure out that to be able to
use this car thingy I'm gonna have to
call insert key press clutch turn key
what I want to do is start right so it
would be much nicer if I could just do
start so you put in a facade that
basically has the method start and then
that makes sure to handle all of the
complexities underneath this is a very
simple sample but there could be way
more complicated things there could be
default values that you might want to
fill in or several calls that needs to
be made to different systems to get
something to work but in the end the
facade will basically take this big
complex system with all of its details
and simple down to an interface that you
know how to use it often very very often
means that you take a very big complex
system that can do a ton of things and
you basically cut off all those features
you go and say we don't need faith
features abcdefg but this little feature
over here that would be kind of cool to
house will do facade cuts of all the
other things gives the user the ability
to use this little part of the system so
we don't have to get this big thing
anybody use a facade look at that most
of you have used these patterns nobody
wanted to explain them um proxy proxy
pretty similar again so a proxy is a
wrapper or an agent object that is being
called by the client to access the real
serving objects once again is a kind of
a thing that you build to be able to
hide something
also wrap something else or basically
make something disappear for you
so what the proxy does is basically you
have a system part of your system that
you need to talk to but it's not part of
your process for example it's not part
of your system it's something running
somewhere else potentially but you need
to call it as if it was a part of your
program you all done this how many of
you have ever called a web service all
of you who do not raise your hands what
do you do for a living because I thought
that was kind of ubiquitous we all do
web services just as way it works it
used to be
WCF and now it's all rest but it's kind
of same thing and what we do with these
services that we need to call is we
create a client object right we create a
version of that object that runs inside
of our program so that when we call a
method on that object it's just as if we
are calling that object the only
difference is that when we're calling
that object it actually sends off the
thing and calls that somewhere else and
in most cases when it comes to web
services they're probably on a different
machine anybody try also thought that
had a rim remoting thing that was really
cool that did the same thing for you but
you could call objects in other
processes I'd forgotten name right now
there are lots of these round
um how many went to Damion Edwards and
David Fowler's talk yesterday about
dotnet core 2.2 you remember that they
said that they were going to add the
ability to right-click and add reference
to a swagger file or yeah that is
creating basically a proxy object for
you it's just that you don't have to do
it yourself you just say my service is
over there here's a definition of my
service just as whistle was for WCF and
it generates code for you for an object
that looks like you're calling it
locally but it's actually being closed
somewhere else it can be other things I
want to mention that it doesn't
necessarily need to be crossing the
internet or things like that but it's a
way for you to call objects that are not
locally local to your application so the
client says I switch in this case the I
switch is implemented by this way
proxy and it calls just toggle and it
doesn't actually know what's happening
it just assumes that I'm calling some
piece of code but in the real world it's
actually going across my weird network
at home maybe I'm turning on the lights
in the ceiling it's really weird that we
are literally turning on lights
wirelessly now but that's why it works
so proxies are kind of useful and then
the last one which is the odd one out it
doesn't quite fit in here but it kind of
does fit in here does anybody know what
a bridge is not a single person okay the
bridge pattern is interesting and you've
all done it I promise you you have all
done this at some point the bridge
pattern blah blah blah is meant to
decouple an abstraction from its
implementation so that the two can vary
independently did that make you smarter
did you mean that that did that make you
understand what the bridge is no because
that's the thing I keep I keep going to
places on the internet and I read about
software development and I read stuff
like that and I go I have no idea what
that meant and I'm like thinking I must
be the only one I must be the only one
that raised this and don't get it at all
because it's still being written like
this but apparently I'm not alone at
least so say that you have an
abstraction that basically is dependent
on two different dimensions so you've
got two things that will vary your
abstraction which might end up being a
lot of different implementations so for
example say that you have a shape
renderer it renders shapes the
implementation of that is default and
high contrast so I have two different
versions of that so I want to be able to
render my shapes in a default version
but I also want to be able to have logic
in order to do high contrast for people
with poor eyesight but then that
implementation also needs to support
both WinForms and WPF right so I've got
two different axes I've got the default
versus high contrast and I got the
platform there I'm running on which is
WinForms and WPF so I end up having to
do four classes here right
I need to do the default WinForms
default WPF hai contracts winform
high-contrast WPF we can all agree on
that right and then your boss comes and
says hey grayscale would be cool
damn it okay so I need to create
grayscale WinForms grayscale WPF now
we're up to six different
implementations that we have to choose
from and then somebody comes to says hey
dude's a Marine is kind of cool oh so we
end up having to do as a marine version
arey front of these so with just three
options in each axis you end up with
nine different implementations does that
seem like a useful solution it's gonna
end up with just blowing up and having
many many many many implementations and
you having to figure out which one to
use so what the bridge pattern says is
let's split it let's split the two axis
into two different things and basically
say we'll have an eye shape renderer
which is implemented by the default and
the high contrast thing that
implementation is in turn dependent on
eye renderer which can then be WinForms
and WPF so I can just go ahead and
implement these things so the default
implemented deep default shape renderer
takes an instance of I renderer to do
the actual rendering so it does a part
of its logic about what it needs to do
and then cause the renderer to do the
actual rendering and the high contrast
one will basically change the colors of
the shape and then send the shape to the
renderer to do the actual rendering so
we end up having to do less code and if
we then go ahead and we add high contra
or grayscale and WPF we just add on each
layer we add a new implementation and we
combine them so we kind of end up or
kind of we end up with a double
abstraction so you get one thing that
abstracts the whole thing but that
abstraction in turn takes a dependency
on another abstraction to do some of its
work I can see that this is the kind of
cool pattern and I'm pretty sure have
you ever anyone done this before
yeah we kind of do this we just didn't
know that was called a bridge but I must
admit I very often take this way further
because basically we've talked about
composition over inheritance
software programming for a while now and
it's kind of this we keep moving things
apart and also we're not just doing two
levels anymore we're passing in and
composing our objects in a way different
ways so this might not be as important
today as it was previously and if we
look at the comparison between the
different different patterns so what
we've got with the adapter which wraps
an implementation of something but it
changes to interface and keeps the
functionality the same right that
correct wraps an implementation of
something it uses the same interface as
the thing that it wraps but it adds
functionality so they are different even
though they look from code very similar
the facade doesn't wrap anything it
basically creates a brand new interface
for you to use but the functionality
behind that interface is going to be
something that's already there so we're
not changing the functionality we're
just cutting down the API or changing
the interface that we won't use without
wrapping it proxy new implementation so
it doesn't wrap anything some form of it
uses the same interface as the other
thing that you're calling it's just
you're calling it locally and that's
being called over there and the function
it doesn't change the functionality and
the bridge is kind of hard to put into
this thing because it's kind of two
layer abstraction thingies so it partly
wraps some of the functionality is
wrapped and some of it is implemented by
the same thing it can use an existing
interface and adding or removing
functionality can depends on what you're
doing with it so let's have a look at
some code and I love the person who put
up a podium for Smurfs so what we're
gonna do here is we're gonna have a look
at so this is the source code that I
said it's on it's on github so I'm just
gonna have a quick look at how these
look so we start with the adapter and I
have a very very simple implementation
here writing everything in one class
seems like a really good idea when I
have a lot of screen real estate when
you go to font size 25 that comes really
small so basically I've got my logger my
logger implementation here it takes a
log level and a message log level is
just an
and then I have a an ilogger
implementation called log4net logger so
basically it wraps log the log for net
logger creates the interface that I need
and translates all each one of these
calls to that interface - cools that
correspond to what log4net expects so
that's that after if we have a look at
next one which is decorator we have the
actually the same sample as I showed you
before don't look at what I'm actually
doing in the main here I've really
stupid code but I want to show you the
patterns not the code so it's all about
is it Friday service and longer and
longer stuff so I've gotten is it Friday
service we all need one of those in our
projects then I have an implementation
of I is it Friday service which you
called is it Friday service which
basically returns whether or not is
Friday and then I have a caching version
of the is it Friday service because
obviously they call to this this call
here is so heavy that we need to cache
the result right can't keep running that
over and over so what the caching thing
does it basically takes an
implementation of I is it Friday service
and the cache configuration that it
needs and whenever we call and
implements is a Friday service and
whenever it's being implemented called
the interface being called is a Friday
it basically looks at can I do something
else do I have a cache value no I don't
then I use the internal version
otherwise I return the cash value so I
added caching to my is the Friday
service and then I have a login version
of it as well so basically every time
this thing takes in I is it Friday
service whenever it's being called it
calls the service but it also Lord logs
out the coals I can see what's going on
so decorators are canonize is a nice way
of basically adding functionality
without doing composition and without
doing inheritance we have the facade in
this case the facade is
basically a it does a login facade here
and it sorry I got the logger up here I
logger and then I my logging facade
logging facade here that basically takes
the logger and goes and sorry I need to
go down here so you can see the the
logger here so the implementation that I
have is the console logger here and the
console logger takes in a type and a
console color and a format and a log
level and a bunch of different things
here and the message and writes that out
to the foreground order to the console
so my facade here to make it simpler for
the user to use this thing I've created
a facade called high logger which has a
simple log method and what that does it
basically makes it very very simple to
call log passing a level and message and
then this thing the facade takes away
all the pain of having to figure out the
type and the color and all other things
that's needed by the system behind not
that I'm saying that that's a
complicated back-end but it's it's kind
of assaulting it at least and finally I
have a proxy here which is once again
and and is it Friday service and yeah
okay so in this case I'm sorry well
since I wrote this specific one and this
thing isn't actually calling anything
off in somewhere else it's just creating
an instance for me so it basically
creates a proxy for an object that's in
memory because I didn't want to go ahead
and build a web service mode that stuff
but what it does it it basically goes
ahead and check some user name
information and then calls the instance
as though it's local so you could
imagine this thing actually calling off
to a web service it was just too much
work to write that having that said your
proxy object doesn't necessarily have to
be remote the definition of a proxy
object is a proxy is actually just
talking to an object which could be
something simple as what I'm doing here
we're just creating an instance of it it
doesn't necessarily need to be somewhere
else it could be a proxy to an object
that is too complicated to create
it kind of becomes a single tongue
through the proxy so very code-wise I'm
going through them quite fast I know but
you've got all the code to play around
with and I do believe that most of them
you can actually go in and press f5 and
it runs which is not what my code
normally does yes oh did I miss the
ridge
yes I did thank you for that bridge to
show off the bridge
I wrote let's kill the main here because
I don't want to show that so once again
I've got a logger but I've taken my eye
logger which has a log method and I've
broken it into a logger and the log
writer sigh but one part that does the
logging in one part that actually writes
it out to the console or to whatever I
want sorry not not the console
specifically and then I've created the
implementation here so the
implementation here is a simple logger
the simple logger takes an I log writer
and creates a very simple log entry for
me thus simple log write simple logger
the advanced one is a bit more
complicated because it rise advanced
ahead of it and also writes out some
time and a few little other things so it
basically adds a bit more to the logging
statement but once again depends on the
log writer to do the actual work it just
formats it and then I have a
configurable thing here where not only
does it take it alot log writer but it
also takes a format that I can use to
basically create my own log system or
log entries and but all of these are
dependent on an implementation of log
writer a log writer so I have a console
log writer and the log4net log writer so
I can basically combine these so today I
want to have the advanced logger with
with log4net and I can combine those so
during development maybe I do a lot of
logging but I want to have more
information so I might do a configurable
logger with some extra information and
just a console logger for my local
machine so we can combine this that's
the bridge thank you for reminding me or
that did all of these makes sort of
sense cool
so visitor pattern this is cool but
really hard to explain why it's cool
it's just one of these you read about it
and you start playing with it and you
saw this it's light bulb lights up and
you go oh that is smart that is really
smart and then think it's really cool
than that one more and you're in the
shower and you're going why is that
really smart
I'm sorry questioning this pattern it
looks really cool but it's it's I'm
coming into there are other ways of
doing that today but I thought I'd show
it so this the visitor pattern is a way
of separating algorithm from an object
structure which is operated which it
operates so you need to add new
algorithms to an object without
modifying them so you might need to say
that you have a shape which happens to
be my example and you need to have a way
of calculating the area of that shape
okay cool I'll add a get area method oh
by the way we're kind of cool if we're
rendering this on screen that you could
also tell me x and y coordinates or you
have an x and y and you want to be able
to figure out where it's positioned on
the screen so I need another algorithm
to that and oh it would be kind of cool
if we also somehow could build a way of
saying I have multiple shapes please
tell me the size of the area I need to
create to be able to render all this
shape and they still fit in and things
like that all of these are new sort of
things that come along the way so often
we go back and we change your objects we
add new functionality to them to support
these new calculations the visitor
pattern basically says no you shouldn't
go and change your object I'll give you
a generic way of adding new features to
your object without having to change the
object so the way that they do it is
item a and item B both explose
a method called except this is generally
named except it's just a method on each
one of these items that takes in a
visitor thus the visitor part the
visitor intern has a method called visit
element which is basically takes an
instance of either item a or item B they
don't need to implement the same
interface they they it's just that the
visitor needs to have a visit element
method that takes in either and I
a or an item V so you can have many many
overloads of the visit element function
so you can do different things for
different elements and what happens is
that the client creates a visitor and
then it tells the item a in this case
that can you please accept this visitor
item A's goes yep I can accept that
visitor so it calls visit element on the
visitor passing itself into the visitor
and then the visitor can go and do stuff
and calculate things and do things to
item a and then you we can use the
visitor to figure out what he came up
with and then I can go and take the same
visitor and pass it in to item B's visit
element and the item B passes itself
into the visitor that then comes back
and uses the item B to do whatever it
needs to do this makes no sense at all
right okay
little caveat here as we're passing if
you go back here as its passing visit
element this the visitor can only use
public things on item B so you cannot go
in and do private things and make
changes to private things but you can
use all of the public API so this makes
more sense if I show you and it is down
here this whole thing of having it in
alphabetical order is complicated so I
have created its I have created a couple
of shapes I've created a square and a
circle and a text object these are
basically things we could render on the
screen they all in this case happen to
implement I am visible you don't need to
do that it just needs to have a method
in this case called accept that accepts
an eye visitor an implementation of
accept is literally visitor visit this
to basically inject itself back into
the visitor the I visitor pattern we go
up here the I visitor pattern is visit
square circle and text so it has for
three different methods each for one tie
each type so it means that when you need
more things that can be visited by this
visitor you need to add another function
which is kind of cool because it doesn't
break open close principle because
you're just adding new things to it and
implementation here I have an area
calculation visitor and if we look at
square here it has the algorithm to
figure out the area for s square area
for a circle and area for a text which
in which case it uses a font size and
some made-up values and this is where
you realize that I'm almost four years
old and I'm happy that my dad is a math
teacher because I could not figure out
how to do a area calculation of a circle
that's that kind of explain house much I
suck at math I learned that over the
Christmas I have a drawing area
calculation visitor so what this oh yeah
so one thing also it's the visitor never
returns the value it's always void but
it can expose the result using a
property so the area calculation visitor
just goes and calculates for one thing
the drawing area calculation visitor
actually goes ahead and adds to the
drawing area to figure out what
rectangle do I need to be able to draw
this thing and if you call that passing
in three different squares and four
different circles and maybe a text area
it will basically figure out how much
space do I need to render all these
things things that I didn't know when I
created the the square and the circle
and the text and then I have a scale by
which actually modifies two objects so I
can go and say I want you to scale by
one point two so basically make it
twenty percent bigger I can pass in a
square and it will make sure that this
square becomes 1.20 twenty percent
bigger area wise same thing with circle
it figures out there's actually math in
here as well that figures out how to
scale your air
a circle to make it bigger in 2020 for a
bigger area and then in my method up
here we can see how it basically
calculate area for example basic girls
creates an error area calculation
visitor takes the visitor visit able
object passes in the area and then on my
area I can figure out my own my visitor
I can figure out the area and I can also
go and say here that one calculates
total drawing area it takes an
ienumerable of I am visible creates a
drawing area calculated visitor goes
through each one of the vegetables
passing in the visitor the visitor just
goes ahead and ads and ads and ads and
at the end here I can go and figure out
this is the rectangle that I need to be
able to draw all of these shapes it's
kind of a cool way of doing it and but
as I said I I go back and forth between
why didn't I just do a why don't you
just create an instance of it and pass
it in without having to do the whole
passing back and forth why have Y take
an object and pass in a visitor and then
have the thing called the visitor versus
just taking the visitor object and
passing the freaking thing straight in
but there are some some architectural
interesting ideas that means that you
don't cause problems with open closed
principle and some other things with the
visitor pattern so the desert batter is
interesting I do suggest that you have a
look at it I am almost 99% sure that you
will probably never use it but it's kind
of cool circuit breaker that's a new one
has anybody heard of the circuit breaker
pattern ooh
ok that was ok there's a lot of people
and so the circuit breaker breaker
pattern is is something we use with
micro-services with all our cases so
it's used to detect failures and
encapsulate the logic of preventing a
failure from constantly recurring so
what we do here in for example in a
micro service or architecture where
we're dependent on calling other systems
all the time and we're doing it probably
a cloud environment and cloud if you if
you're building cloud you know that you
always have to take into account that
stuff might not be available right stuff
goes up and down and it's being moved
around and there might be temporary
outages and if you're working with a
database for example
ah sure which I know more than AWS I
know that in Asher for example if you
talk to sequel sequels responsibility in
a series to protect itself so if you
start hammering your database sequel
server will actually start returning air
errors going saying I'm not I'm not
doing that because my main priority is
to survive if you try to kill me by
overloading me I'm gonna stop responding
so we need to take into account that we
have what is called transient failures
in the cloud in a lot of cases and
that's where the circuit breaker comes
in so the first problem we're trying to
solve are just a transient failures so
you're dependent on other services but
they might be in a state where they are
potentially failing or they're really
really slow but the problem is that when
you for example call a web service that
is failing you might have a timeout so
you might be waiting for that thing to
respond for maybe 20 seconds if you have
a heavy load system and you keep sending
requests to that and each one of those
requests have to wait 20 seconds your
system is going to get really slow bad
problem and it's basically once again it
has to be a transient fault because what
you want to do is you want to make sure
that you don't have to wait for 20
seconds all the time
but you don't want to go and say that
thing is broken we have to redeploy the
system or we need to solve it because it
might be a transient thing that
disappears and the second problem is
that that thing that is having the
problems it might be stuck on something
else and it's trying to survive and it's
trying to get over its own problem it's
trying to heal from something else but
at the same time you're hammering it
with requests continuously using up a
bunch of its resources so while it's
trying to survive of a failure somewhere
else potentially you're adding more load
to it basically crushing the service so
you might end up with a cascading
failure situation so what you've got
with the circuit breaker is that you
wrap that logic so you take a thing you
take your request and you wrap it into
piece an object and then that object
basically keeps track of failing
requests and then you can have a trip on
it so basically saying once you've done
this call and it has failed for more
than five times in a row I want you to
kill it so whenever somebody tries to
make that request again just throw an
exception straight off don't wait
20 seconds don't make the request don't
load the other server just kill it just
whenever somebody calls it just kill it
because it's offline and then maybe
after 20 seconds or after at set amount
of time it might say I'm gonna let one
call through and then it makes the
throws for everything else but let's one
call through if that call succeeds it
will then go and say I might load up
some more calls and let some more
traffic go through and then once the
thing comes back online in full power it
will basically just back off and say you
can now do your calls as you wish so the
logic of being able to do backups and
basically canceling things like that go
since your circuit breaker so if we look
at the circuit breaker here I have a
very simple implementation of it so the
circuit breaker here it's basically an
HTP circuit breaker what it does it has
a max failure in the retry count and
when you do call execute on it with the
thing that it's a generic thing that I
built it uses a callback function so
basically it's if it's a takes a func
that returns a task of HTTP response
message and it basically wraps that and
checks to see is the current state of
the circuit breaker open basically it's
it's turned off then ad failure count
and return null basically just go and
say don't don't make the call because
it's not broken otherwise make the
request and then it makes requests and
it basically puts in a try-catch if it
fails it as a failure count to it and
then we could have things like so
failure count here has logic to say that
if the current state is open and failure
count blah blah blah and re crunch our
account it could have it trying to close
things so basically let's something
through let's one thing through and then
nothing else and it can be open and
closed so you call this thing I wouldn't
use this code it's just a sample but
what you do here is you go request
helper don't make requests it takes a
circuit breaker and a client and it
makes the call for me and the circuit
breaker is being passed in there's a
generic thing that I can have I could
have more of those four different calls
for example but the idea is keeping
track of failed calls for example and
basically be able to short-circuit
the whole thing and say I you have
failed now so for a while now I'm not
going to let you go ahead and do that
anymore
you can also do that not just for
failures you could go and have a circuit
breaker that says if these calls starts
take you start taking more than X amount
of time we might want to back off and
not let all of them through and let the
service that we're calling heal up the
circuit breaker is kind of cool and it's
one of those things that you can do in a
fairly generic way if you know what
you're doing and it can help you out
quite a lot when it comes to depending
on a bunch of other services make sense
cool and then we have the one that
everybody uses and nobody knows how to
use the repository pattern how many of
you have not implemented a repository at
some point you are lucky because that
means I can't yell at you the repository
pattern is very very common we use that
all over the place
everybody goes we need a repo it needs
to be repository we need okay a
repository abstracts away the data layer
and centralizes the retrieval of domain
objects that's me
it was not me APD I couldn't find
repository pattern on Wikipedia with a
nice definition so I brought my own and
it basically it's just a layer on top of
your data access that gives you a way of
getting domain objects so the problem
that you have is you need to get domain
objects because domain objects are
persistent ignorant in a domain driven
development environment there they are
there but persistence is a different
thing right so we create a repo or
repository and it gives us the ability
to go and say can I get a user with this
ID and it hides all the database logic
and it goes and gets me a fully working
user object that I can use in my domain
model suite very very simple demo that
is very very short presentation I'm
going to tell you why it doesn't work
repository I have a very simple sample
here I use entity framework and my repo
down here is I used repository
implemented by use repository and I
actually love this syntax here and I
want to talk thank a guy called Jimmy
Anderson in Sweden for that he made me
change the way there
my repos so these method names are quite
odd right normally you have where user
is admin aware or sorry and by ID or
admins or whatever but adding methods
like this called who are admins and that
have been deleted whose first name
starts with look kind of odd light here
but if you go up in here and read it
it's very readable VAR users in users
whose first name starts with C makes it
a bit read it more readable than get by
ID get by admin get by blah blah blah
anyhow this is all it does it has a
user's context in this case which is an
entity framework thing it has two
implementation here I do not and you
should not here are a couple of things
that I dislike about people doing with
repositories one I don't like people who
expose iqueryable the idea behind a repo
is to hide database access and make sure
that people get objects based on defined
queries it's supposed to hide the query
logic of how to get your object if you
start exposing iqueryable here then
you're spreading that logic of how to
find an object throughout your entire
system so the data access logic is
spread out throughout the system and
then somebody comes and says let's add
soft deletes to this so you're never is
supposed to get something that has this
the delete that flag equals true ah crap
you have to go around and rewrite all of
your access logic because it's spread
out across your application because you
haven't iqueryable there should be
predefined methods giving you specific
things hiding query logic next thing
here you can see that I have an add and
a delete method what is missing a save
method the repository should not be
responsible for saving things the
repository isn't there to retrieve
objects not save them there should be
other logic that figures out that once
you've retrieved the object if you
change that object and you call save on
something it should be saved so if
you're using entity framework here for
example entity frameworks con
we'll internally keep track of that
object so the context will know whether
or not Knoblauch needs to be saved so
the context has the ability to save and
save objects from many different
repositories in the same transaction if
you add a save method to your repository
that is dangerous when it comes to
entity framework because if you add a
safe method to the user repository and
you call save and you go user context
dot save you're actually saving every
changed object in that context not just
users so you're not saving that stuff
from the user repository
you're saving objects from any kind of
repository that has ever retrieved
anything from that context in that
process so don't add a save save is
something else because you might be
reading stuff from different repos so
you need to make sure that changes from
objects in different repositories should
be saved in one single transaction no
saves but Chris how the hell are we
gonna do saves them I will show you
so saves do not go into your repository
it's for retrieval which is why unity
work comes up unit of work is according
to Martin Fowler maintains a list of
objects affected by a business
transaction and coordinates the writing
of changes and the resolution of
concurrency problems that sounds like
saving stuff so what we do is that we
basically have something that keeps
track of all of our modified entities
and makes it possible for us to persist
it as one atomic thing like a
transaction so if you have an entity
framework for example their context is a
unit of work you create a context you
get stuff out of the context you modify
objects on that context and you call
save on that context and the context is
your unit of work because once you call
save on the context it will save all
changed objects in that context however
you do not want to go ahead and spread
your your entity framework context
around and have them spread out because
you hide them in the repository so how
do we go about
hiding the context while still used and
using by using repositories but not
exposing a safe method in the repository
well I have a very very simple demo of
that there are other ways of doing this
but imagine I do think no actually I
don't have an entity framework worst
version I'm sorry about that what I've
got is an in-memory store in this case
but what we do is we well actually this
does what you could have done so the
interface are I support unit of work has
a complete method my implementation
which is my repository in this case it's
just in memory implements I support unit
of work but it implements it explicitly
so if I use this thing as an in-memory
store I'm not going to see the complete
method I need to cast it to that
interface to actually get access to it
and then I have my unit of work which
takes a I support unit work item and
calls complete on it when you complete
the unit work so I could go ahead and
register multiple I support unit work in
this unit of this unit of work class and
then what you do is up here I create a
unit of work I go ahead and make some
changes to it and then I call unit of
work complete to basically do the save
and then the unit of work is the thing
that basically wraps everything up and
makes sure it's being persisted I would
recommend that you you do something like
this and figure out a way to handle this
if you're doing repositories and I also
recommend that your unit of work thing
implements I disposable so that you can
basically base in wrap it in a using
statement for example and roll back
stuff that you don't want to have so
within the using statement unless you
call complete on it it rolls back stuff
if you don't have that then entity
framework you might after your unit of
work there are actually changes left in
memory that shouldn't be there for
example so unit of work is where your
safe method should be and it should not
be part of your repository and that's
where I'm saying a lot of people are
doing it in quotes wrong because they
expose iqueryable spreading out query
logics throughout the application and
they have a safe method on each one of
their and repository
which means that you're actually
potentially saving way more than you're
supposed to yes no yes no no you could I
in this case I'm limiting it to entity
framework because entry framework
happens to believe have an
implementation of unit of work in
already
yeah so you don't want yeah so that's
the thing the pattern repository
shouldn't have a safe method so I'm not
they're all a part of different things
so basically each pattern is its own
thing for its own specific problem where
the repository already the repository
pattern is retrieval of objects you
could go and say that your unit of work
was your repository as well if you
wanted to but it kind of in that case
you should know that your unit of work
is your repository and the way we're
having a unit of work as a defined thing
you you know that a unit of work is this
the problem with repositories that don't
the unit of work is if you go and save
you as I said your entity framework
context or you're in hybrid context or
your other thing you might actually be
saving things that you didn't intend to
say because you don't really know what
the unit of work is for example if you
do entity framework for example or you
do any form of over ms in asp net core
and you put it into your idea your ioc
container and you leave it in the ioc
container for the entire request you
might be doing things in the ioc
container in the the repository sorry in
the context your unit work in different
areas and then at the end of it you save
and you don't actually know what you're
saving but yes it is it some things do
limit other things um and then I got
factories another one of my favorites
when do this very very fast so and a
factory is an object for creating other
objects or basically it returns
an object or a subclass of that object
the problem that you have is that you
don't want to use new if you start
mooing up objects in your code you're
coupling your class to that other class
so by using a factory you can go and get
an instance of that type but you don't
tie yourself to specific implementations
new is really not a great keyword demo
for that actually sorry I'm a little bit
short there is code in there it's
basically just factory function so you
call get a new object here are the
parameters I need like basically like a
constructor but you do it on a different
object that then returns not a specific
instance but something that implements I
did that instance or a subclass or an
interface whatever but basically it
allows you to vary the objects that
you're getting back it also allows you
to get away from the fact that if you
have constructor parameters you have
multiple constructors for a method and
they overlap in the type of types you
can't have two constructor parameters
type that hate string for example or two
constructors that both just take a
string as a parameter using a factory
you can actually have multiple
constructors that just take a string and
then it completely configures the object
for you before it's being returned back
and my final pattern which is really not
that big is just I love this and people
miss it
null object a null object is an object
with no referenced value or with define
neutral or null behavior so it's about
having null checks all over the place I
hate having the if blah blah blah equals
null then do this otherwise do that or
rather often you end up writing this
right if flog is not equal to null right
out this but you end up having these if
log not equals to null all over your
code because you don't know if it's null
so you don't want to call it and c-sharp
doesn't have a handle not very well it
would be kind of nice if we just wrote
that right so what we do is we create a
null logger which implements the I log
interface but it doesn't do anything
it's just an empty class it does it has
empty methods it just doesn't do
anything and we have a logger instead of
setting it to null you pass in a null
logger so you can call it but it doesn't
you do anything so
you get rid of all these if statements
or for this for example you call users
dot admins to get all of your admins and
then you do if admins not equals to null
or say if I didn't find any admins I get
a null back but if I did and admins I
get an array why not just return an
array all the time but return as an
empty array so I don't have to do the
check for if admins equals null I can go
and check I always get an object back
whether or not there anything in there
ray that's a whole different story but
you get away from all of these null
checks by having what is like an object
but it's still an empty object it
doesn't exist but you don't have to
check for it demo for that it's also
really stupid basically I'm doing this
I'm just making sure that returns
objects for you sorry I'm right at time
that's why I didn't do it big code
you've got all of my code down here at
that address there is more stuff in
there I wrote some other things with
object pools and some other patterns and
I thought were really cool that you can
have a look at other than that thank you
so much for listening and don't forget
to do the evals if you liked the session
do a green note if you didn't like the
session come up and tell me why I'll
make it better and then explain why it
was awesome and then you do a green on
the way out afterwards okay great
[Applause]